[Música]
en los desiertos del suroeste de eeuu
renacuajos del sapo pata de pala salen
de los huevos en pequeñitos oasis hasta
que se vuelven sapos jóvenes no pueden
sobrevivir fuera del agua pero estos
charcos son transitorios y se evaporan
rápidamente los renacuajos hacen una
carrera contra el tiempo para crecer
antes de que desaparezcan sus criaderos
así que casi de la noche a la mañana
algunas crías multiplican su tamaño usan
dientes de linternas de calabaza e
inmensos músculos de la mandíbula para
devorar a los compañeros de charcos más
pequeños nutridos por la comida extra se
desarrollan más rápido saliendo del
charco antes de que se seque
el sapo pata de pala no es el único
animal que come miembros de su propia
especie como parte normal de su ciclo de
vida todos estos animales lo hacen si
eso les sorprende están en buena
compañía hasta hace poco los científicos
pensaron que el canibalismo era una
escasa respuesta a la inanición u otro
estrés extremo
caníbales bien conocidos como la mantis
religiosa y la araña viuda negra se
consideraban excepciones extrañas pero
ahora sabemos que más o menos
representan la regla
aunque puede parecer contraproducente
que miembros de la misma especie se
comen entre sí el canibalismo puede
promover la supervivencia de la especie
entera reduciendo la competencia
eliminando a los débiles y fortaleciendo
a los fuertes algunas especies como el
sapo pata de pala canibalizan debido a
presiones medioambientales su situación
es precaria pero su canibalismo no es un
intento desesperado de evitar la
inanición más bien es una manera de
pasar más rápidamente por una etapa
cuando son especialmente vulnerables a
la depredación oa condiciones
medioambientales peligrosas otras
especies incluso muchos peces se
canibalizan indiscriminadamente durante
el forraje
[Música]
los peces producen numerosas crías
pequeñitas y los adultos muestran casi
el mismo reconocimiento individual a sus
crías como los humanos por un puñado de
pasas
larvas y peces jóvenes son comidas
nutritivas y fáciles de conseguir y con
miles de huevos en una apuesta todavía
hay muchos que eclosionan después de que
los adultos han merendado los peces
bebés no sólo corren el riesgo de ser
canibalizados por adultos los hermanos
se comen también los huevos del tiburón
toros se desarrollan y eclosionan dentro
de los conductos de la madre en
diferentes momentos cuando las crías
consumen la yema de sus propios huevos
comen los otros huevos y crías hasta que
un tiburón bebé queda en cada oviducto
cuando salen los tiburones jóvenes son
depredadores expertos y bien alimentados
que tienen mejores oportunidades de
sobrevivir si bien no fueron consumidos
por falta de nutrientes los animales
jóvenes son especialmente vulnerables al
canibalismo hámsteres ratas y otras
madres roedores comerán a sus crías si
están enfermos muertos o simplemente son
demasiados para alimentar en otros
mamíferos incluso osos y leones los
machos matarán a las crías engendradas
por otro esto se debe a que las hembras
sin hijos son receptivas al apareamiento
más rápido que si cuidaran a un cachorro
antes que desperdiciar carne nutritiva
los machos comen a los cachorros muertos
mientras tanto el canibalismo es menos
común en las aves que en otros grupos
pero ciertas especies comerán crías
enfermas o muertas como manera de
eliminar los cuerpos antes que atraigan
gusanos
cuando los adultos se comen canibalizan
a los machos más que a las hembras
generalmente durante el apareamiento y
porque son más chiquitos
machos arañas espaldas rojas
australianos aparean con hembras mucho
más grandes en vez de huir después de
aparearse
el macho chiquito hace una voltereta
poniendo su vientre en contacto con la
boca de su pareja
la hembra lo rocía con jugo gástrico
lleno de enzimas y consume su vientre
los machos no muertos por el apareo
inicial se arrastran hacia la batalla a
menudo medio comidos a parear de nuevo
después de lo cual se les envían a la
bodega de las arañas así que el macho no
solamente provee su esperma a la hembra
sino que también provee una comida
nutritiva para asegurar que sobrevivirá
a pasar sus genes
[Música]
considerando todo está claro que el
canibalismo están con una parte de la
vida en el reino animal como otras
conductas mejores reconocidas mientras
hincamos el diente en la evidencia del
canibalismo en la naturaleza nos
podríamos preguntar qué más hemos
perdido al aplicar los estándares
humanos al mundo de la naturaleza
quieres saber más suscríbase a nuestro
canal manténgase conectado tenga
curiosidad
[Música]